hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday
um January 23rd
2023. oh wow 123 23.
I'm gonna go I'm gonna go put that on
one of them [__] scratch tickets
I can't remember the last time I bought
one of those
the old scratch ticket right and then
what happened you hit it for 700 bucks
and you open your mouth the next thing
you know you got to buy all your
[__] French drinks
right
and they start answer ordering fancy
[__] and you're [__] sitting there
looking at them like what a [__]
you think if this guy hits 700 bucks on
a scratch ticket he'd [__] let me
know about it he turns around
and he's gonna do a shot at Johnny
Walker Blue
think I don't have [__] bills to pay
that's how people get killed they get
killed with those scratch tickets it
happens I've seen it I've seen a HBO
Undercover
about it
um
I'm hanging out here in my uh my lack of
a podcast Studio I'm still trying to get
my [__] microphones fixed here
um
and I am watching the Bengals versus the
bills
it's 27 to 10.
27 to 10 and if you didn't see this
[__] game coming you didn't watch
them against the Dolphins last week with
a very underwhelming performance against
the Miami Dolphins and some guy named
Skyler something or other at quarterback
um which I was talking about like I
think this is like the Golden Age of
backup quarterbacks
because I'll tell you when I was growing
up God damn it with a backup quarterback
came in he [__] stunk
I'm trying to think
that's a great question
the all-time greatest backup quarterback
send your submissions all right I don't
even I'm trying to name back up
quarterbacks when I was
unless you had a quarterback controversy
where they had like Pat Hayden and Vince
Ferragamo or or David Woodley and
um
and something else what is the other Don
strzok
um all right here's what fascinates me
here about this game here this guy 88
just caught one ran a [__] seam route
I think that is we run right down the
hash marks is that what it's called
I don't know what
and all of a sudden they're going to go
to work go into a hurry up offense this
is where I feel like Vegas made a phone
call being like all right people are
shutting off this game at least make it
27-24
you know to end it
right uh anyway I'm trying to think like
backup quarterbacks
back in the I've just never seen an era
where that's happened but I'm not here
to talk about that I'm not here to talk
about playoff football and that quit
snow
that's fallen in Baltimore hey wait Bill
how can you be doing a podcast while
coaching the bills at the same time
final proof that I am not that guy he's
also in better shape than I am
um
I just took my daughter my wife and my
daughter to Disneyland for my daughter's
sixth birthday and I gotta tell you this
I had a [__] blast
I had a great time I don't know what all
these [__] parents are bitching about
you know I I know I know they got the
deal there where they [__] you get
off the right I like now when you go
there's you get off the ride and you
immediately go into a gift shop that has
got more [__] merchandise than that
[__] band KISS I mean it's
unbelievable
we went to uh Tomorrowland like oh my
god let's go to the land of tomorrow
let's see what does a blitz he got some
um are they calling that a fumble
they're not calling that a fumble even a
podcaster with bad eyes knows that his
arm was moving forward
maybe it wasn't
Josh Allen slow to get up
um
Hendrickson proving that what he has in
his hand is indeed a football
yeah his hand was it was his arm was
going forward what are we doing
yeah
on the replay
all right anyway this rule is available
on the play we're now gonna [__] go
through nine hours of uh
investigative reporting to see if that
was in fact an incomplete forward pass
um
yeah dude the level of [__] March out
there but what I did like though was the
amount of parents
that were like all about it they were
like so into it they had the ears on
they were dressing like characters and
all of that [__] and uh we stayed at a
hotel near the premises
and um
my daughter went with one of her or her
oh not one of her what literally went
with her best friend which was great we
went with another family which was
perfect
because they're cool and their kid's an
absolute sweetheart and uh so I just
knew it would be a better experience if
she could go with another kid the first
time
at Disneyland so we went there and uh we
went downstairs for breakfast and I
swear to God
Mickey Mouse was there Minnie Mouse
Pluto and I don't know if it was Chip or
Dale
my daughter knew I guess like their
noses are different
so we got pictures with all of them I
saw Goofy for half a second
but then he like he like dipped out or
whatever
and I'm sitting there and I was took me
back to when I I went to Disney World
a long long long [__] time ago
put it this way the last time I was at
Disney World they were building Epcot
Center
um and they were talking about how
amazing it was going to be and all of
that stuff
I can't remember if I went there in this
I think I went in the 70s and then one
more time in my in the 80s
but I remember because I was a little
kid I remember they were having the
parade going down Main Street and all I
wanted to do was Meet goofy I thought
goofy was the funniest and the best
character and all of that so the person
in the goofy suit was skipping down the
street I remember Pluto was just walking
down the street shaking people's hands
on one side where Goofy
was skipping across going over the
middle
right like what not not even worried
about Ray Lewis just going over the
middle and he was skipping from side to
side and I sat there going goofy
goofy goofy like you're not even
understanding How Sound travels is that
the [__] dude could not hear me and
of course he skipped on past I didn't
get to shake his hand I never met him
and it bugged me and then I went there
when I was a little bit older
still didn't meet him right
so today
we go downstairs for breakfast
and uh lo and behold oh no wait wait I
missed it we went into the park
and who's standing there taking pictures
with a line of people is [__] goofy
I'm like oh [__] I've been waiting for
this picture for over 40 years so I
stand in line with my daughter and I get
there one of the Disney people's just
like yeah Goofy's got a show man he's
got to go he's got to go so like this is
the end of the line and I went all right
I get it you got to be the bad guy no
worries no problem he says all right
cool and then Cruella Deville was
hanging out and uh
my friend was saying that Cruella is
like the best character to play because
you can like openly [__] on people
because it's part of your character like
like my kid and the other kid that she
was with were like screaming at one
point and the Cruella developed pressure
ah who's making that awful noise or
something
[Laughter]
was kind of awesome and she was being
all arrogant and acting like you know
she was the [__] I really enjoyed
meeting her but I didn't get to meet
goofy right so
I'm leaving and we're going downstairs
to go to breakfast and I'm thinking like
all right you know
this is the last little breakfast thing
here you know the last little 900 for
[__] poached eggs I'm gonna have to
pay for
and we show up breakfast and who's
standing there doing a [__]
step and repeat pictures or whatever is
Goofy
right
the Buffalo Bills driving with nine
minutes to go the Buffalo Bills are
driving I'm just saying this for me
because by the time this is posted this
game will be over
um
[__] Goofy standing there so I stand
in line
it's like you know five sets of parents
sets of parents not just parents five
sets of parents like two and three
people they all went to Disney together
and they're standing in line standing in
line and we get down to like one family
in front of us and Goofy just [__] be
just bounces he walks
and I'm like what the [__] and then the
lady goes oh goofy just had to go take a
quick break but blah blah blah I'm like
all right the guy you know the guy's got
to take a leak
worst case scenario would dump this will
be a good seven minutes he's coming back
he washed his hands he's got the white
gloves on all right this is cool Goofy's
coming back we stand there for seven to
ten minutes
and [__] Pluto comes walking around
the corner like this is like
an acceptable
substitute
it reminded me way back in the day when
I went to the Boston Garden to go see
the ice capades and Dorothy Hamill the
Olympic gold medal Medal winner for
women's in 1976 was supposed to be doing
the figure skating and right as the
lights went down they go we're sorry
Dorothy Hamill will not be skating
all right [__] uh Skyler what's his
face from the [__] Miami Dolphins is
gonna everybody's like oh what the [__]
we're up that's what we came out for
she was like America's sweetheart like
all the chicks were going out getting
her hair cut even Shirley from Laverne
and Shirley that TV show had a Dorothy
Hamill [__] haircut and she [__]
she bounced she dipped whatever the kids
say just like Goofy
so
[__] dude leaves and then Pluto comes
back around I got [__] again
and my wife was laughing she because she
always calls little me when she thinks
when I tell his stories from my
childhood she always goes oh baby baby
I'm walking away
and she's just laughing she just goes I
go the guy [__] dipped and Pluto came
back and she laughed
I go I've been waiting to get that photo
for over 40 years and then she goes oh
so I put my head down and act like I'm
all set she goes baby baby
[Laughter]
um
and then I don't know we went we ordered
some other stuff but I gotta say
something man I had a great time once
you got in the park Jesus Christ they
got this Downtown Disney whatever the
[__] that is
um I will say though we saw this band
there the night before
uh Mexican band killing it
killing it was that fourth and sixth
oh you gotta run you got to run the link
to the field no no no no no no no don't
try to pass it over here oh no you don't
um that's the ball game right there
ladies and gentlemen
that was not even a good thrown ball why
is he acting as though he did something
I I swear to God
um
I I I'm gonna say this because I wanted
to be true I want to retire as a sports
fan and I feel like
what the eagle the Philadelphia Eagles
head coach did
like playing to the camera
like he's not coaching a team nodding
vigorously after whatever the Eagles did
and says I know what the [__] I'm doing
like that's good like the amount of
young coaches that saw that and is like
I'm gonna do my version of that it was
bad enough
when they did a half hour segment on the
[__] Ravens field goal kicker I I
didn't watch it I just saw the
advertising where he also sings in an
acapella but we'll give that's a [__]
kicker who gives a [__]
oh and he's got an attitude when he
kicks that ball
like now now let me get this now now
that now a kicker is a personality I
have to deal with that and then it
becomes
[__] now a coach is gonna be a
personality now he's gonna be wagging
his finger he's going to be shaking his
head he's going to be like at one point
he was Hamming it up so bad the NFL
literally did a 360 shot around him the
same shot Tarantino used on Pam Grier
and [__] uh Jackie Brown when she was
coming out of the goddamn dressing room
they did that to an NFL coach who looked
like some jerk off that's out there
shoveling a driveway
if that's gonna I was just trying to
picture Tom Landry nodding vigorously
with this fedora
saying I know what the [__] I'm doing
um
yeah I am uh
if that's how it's done now
that's for the kids Bill don't be the
[__] grumpy old man all right okay I
get it the Eagles head coach just
reinvented a football strategy
he is he is the greatest football coach
he must be he must be because I never
saw Vince Lombardi do that I never saw
Chuck Knoll I never saw Don Shula I
didn't see Bill Parcells I didn't see
Joe Gibbs I didn't see Bill Belichick I
didn't never seen any of them not
vigorously even after they were
absolutely destroying the other team and
say I know what the [__] I'm doing
um
and what I hate about that behavior is
one of these days he's going to get his
[__] ass kicked because that's what
happens and he will not then shake his
head no vigorously into the camera and
say evidently I don't know what the [__]
I'm doing that's not how that game works
the you mad bro game is that's not how
it works it's when you did something
great you got to get in everybody's face
but when you drop a pass a [__] the bed
or any of that then it's it's quiet time
inside voices inside voices everybody
um
anyway sorry
yes if I wasn't being an old man I
wouldn't be the old man that I was
um
you know what I gotta be honest with you
I would love to stop watching sports
and just [__] walk away from it it
would be [__] amazing with all of
that free time what would I do with it
I'm just afraid that I would lose all of
my friends because I would have no idea
what they were talking about
all right I'm gonna do underrated
overrated
at Disneyland
all right under the number one
underrated thing at Disneyland is the
turkey leg they sell these giant turkey
legs and the other dad that I was with
wanted one
and my wife was in line to get me a
burger and then she made the executive
decision
to get to have me get a turkey leg
instead of a burger and I'm looking at
her like why wouldn't you just get me
what I ordered and you know what she did
she nodded at me vigorously and she said
because I know what the [__] I'm doing
laughs
I was sort of indifferent
I was indifferent about the burger I
will be honest because when we first got
there we went to this Tahiti themed or
Tiki themed I don't know what it was it
was like these torches and I swear to
God I ordered a burger and before I
finished saying how I wanted it it came
out of the kitchen and I was like that
is not a good sign that Patty has that's
going to be medium and that has been
sitting on the side of the grill that
doesn't have the flame on staying warm
did you even melt the [__] cheese it
was horrific
all right and I'm sitting there going
this is the happiest place in the world
because it came here so fast why don't
you take your [__] time
and cook it the way I said right
anyway
so I wasn't too upset you know
she said I just you know told him to get
you a turkey leg and some corn
and I'm like all right and in my head
I'm like
what if I change your [__] order I
never heard the end of that but anyway
I'm so glad she did
this dude came back with these turkey
legs they were they were unfucking
believable
and considering all this [__] that you
could be eating there that you're not
eating in that moment and you're just
eating a bunch of protein
it was [__] fantastic
[__] fantastic and then the ear of
corn like I would literally go back to
Disneyland
walk past all the rides
I'd walk past everything except for
goofy because I would stand in line
again just to have that [__]
walk away from me
you know what I mean
I'm like [__] dinero in Casino like
when are you gonna just let that broad
get take her jewelry and leave
um
anyway
I'm going Sam Rothstein I'm going as him
for Halloween
I already got it down I already know
what the [__] I'm gonna do
I'm gonna go on to indochino and get me
what Sam Rothstein [__] suit for 3.99
anyway all right underrated overrate
underrated you gotta get the [__]
turkey leg
you eat that turkey leg first you're
gonna be full for the rest of the day
you're not gonna be eating a bunch of
[__] right you get that [__] turkey
leg and that ear corn and you are good
to go it's over by the teacups
all right there's a food cart over by
the [__] teacups that's what you want
I don't know what land it's in I think
it was in right now bill
um
it was not in Tomorrowland by the way
which I had a good time over there
it's the first time my daughter got to
drive me in a car and she didn't want to
do it I go I'll I'll work the
accelerator right no biggie oh [__] Joe
Mixon
almost broke it
um
these poor [__] Buffalo Bills fans
I mean what did they what in the [__]
did these people do to the foot have you
ever seen a [__] team
just year in year out decade in decade
out Century in how [__] long do they
gotta knock on the door before it opens
50 years of watching play watching
[__] professional football I've never
seen somebody
take a shoulder pad to the chest and
have their heart stopped the first time
it happens who does it happen to a
Buffalo Bill of course it does
of course it does
um anyway
any [__] way look at these bills fans
staying there into the end in that
shitty [__] weather
incredible fan bait I gotta tell you
thank God they have parody in this
league because the owner would have
thrown a temper tantrum said I want a
new [__] stadium and what a left and
all of that [__] so at least that
happened well my Super Bowl pick
for
2022 football season has about four
minutes and 53 seconds left of life
in their season
Jesus Christ dude when they when they
added Norm van brocklin
sorry Von Miller
what is this guy doing he's spanking
that ass is that what he's doing is he
is he throwing dirt on it I don't know
what he's doing but of course we got to
glorify that [__] Behavior
um
that's buddy money is an Eagles fan he
goes I love when that guy nodded into
the camera he goes there's a great [__]
you to the Giants it's like isn't
beating them 38-7 enough of a [__] you
and why do you have to say [__] you
you know I don't know I blame it on
I blame all of this stupid behavior on
dress down Fridays
you know when I was a kid when I was
just a lad bat they'd
they had margarine we weren't churning
butter it wasn't that long ago they came
up with that dress down Friday
right everybody used to dress like they
were going to [__] work and then that
day where they they made one day a week
a [__] slumber party for whatever
stupid [__] reason
all right and then the chicks all got to
try to out [__] each other the other
guys are trying to show off their
[__] guns this whole [__] they
they brought in like this like you were
going to a swingers party and there was
going to be a big [__] orgy that vibe
all of a sudden the professionalism went
out the [__] window and then I think
right around that time it it just
that was the beginning of it that was
the beginning of it
and then I don't know what else happened
and then somewhere along the line social
media came along
and then somehow the goat went from
being a bad thing to a good thing the
goat when I was a kid if you were the
goat of the game I don't know where it
came from but that meant you were the
guy that [__] the game up for
everybody then greatest of all time
became goat and you know
it gets thrown around there's like so
many goats out there now they literally
have a goat emoji
I feel if you were truly talking about
the goat you should have to spell it out
because there's so few of them right oh
oh man I keep trying not to be this guy
this is what it is oh look at the guy
false start on the offense
replayed it down it's a five-yard
[__] penalty
it's getting chippy out there the bills
are out of time out
um Joe burrow everybody Joe burrow is he
gonna go in there
who's gonna win
the purse thrower or job
a Joe burrow
you guys you know I love Patrick Mahomes
I just it's one it's one of my old man
things so I'm like that is a forward
lateral
okay and now that that's legal fine I'll
say that that's you know but at the end
of the day that is a two-yard pass can
everybody settle the [__] down
um
gee what the [__] was I just looking at
that that guy was doing an Oompa Loompa
dance
isn't there enough personality in the
[__] game anybody does anything on
the sidelines I now have to make sure I
see it and now it became like the head
coach of the [__] Eagles that [__]
guy got more goddamn screen time
than than [__] uh the the quarterback
for Duke for the Giants
um sorry anyway
also underrated
underrated at the um
at Disneyland okay as far as like the
rides that I went on with kids I like
the teacups
you know it's a good ride to get your
kid
used to uh you know
some of the faster rides you spin around
a little bit you can control how you
spin but you can also let go of it and
kind of have a nice time it gives you
the option right
I like the uh Pirates of the Caribbean
that's a great one for the parents
you're a little tired they make you walk
up some stairs or whatever
and a couple of nice drops in it I
needed a third one
and then I thought it was kind of funny
that they just sort of rear-end each
other at the end of the end of the ride
I enjoyed that driving on the cars was
cool
um we didn't go in any my kids aren't
big so we didn't go into the big [__]
but um let's see any anything I went on
that I didn't like
I kind of stunk
um
that was all right I wasn't a big fan of
the ones that like they then walked you
through a uh a gift shop like we did
some Star Wars [__] and then the end of
it we're in some gift shop and my
daughter was like assembling uh her own
lightsaber you can pick out whatever
colors you want
and
Nia just jumped in it's like we'll we'll
get that later because you have to carry
that all around the park so
you know two seconds later they forget
about it
um
it was another one what's this guy why
is this guy acting like he's not down by
contact
uh sorry anyway
Billy's trying to make something happen
but overall I gotta tell you like all of
these parents were telling me what a
[__] nightmare going to Disneyland
was going to be it wasn't that bad
it wasn't that bad the lines weren't
that bad or whatever
it was a lot of cool [__] you know
I think well you know when when the kids
get bigger or something like that they
want to run around the park because I
get freaked out by that [__] I don't
like having my kids out of my sight ever
um I'm beyond a helicopter parent
I've just seen too much of this [__]
about human trafficking and all that
stuff which just it [__] blows my
mind that there's not more media
coverage about that trying to end that
[__] there's more media coverage
about you know Caitlyn Jenner that year
where they made her [__] woman of the
year and she had literally literally
killed somebody in a [__] traffic
accident that year
uh that was a joke in my act and she
knew he knew he was going to jail and
the only way he could get out of it is
if he turned himself into a white woman
oh that was a fun topical joke for about
two months
um
anyway
uh let's do the uh
let's do some of the advertisement here
but overall yeah man I I had a
I had a great [__] time and um
next time I do Orlando or something or
one of these times I do Jacksonville or
something I should bring the kids
because I have not been
because I was a little disappointed in
how the castle looked
because I'm used to the the white one
the one that's in Orlando not that
whatever the [__] that one that was like
a uh it was like half a castle
um which by the way that was my only
criticism when I was there could they
have more pictures of Walt Disney
pointing at something while it's being
built it's like we get it this was his
idea
my God it's like [__]
you know he was making Steve Job look
[__] understated
yeah
was there ever a [__] guy in history
that just was just walking around
blowing himself
you know what I mean
do you think it would be Einstein with
some of the shirt that Tesla guy some of
the [__] he came up with no it wasn't
it was the guy who couldn't write any uh
a line of programming or whatever the
[__] they say I don't know what that
even means I should even say that oh
here's he is an old man moment I had
when I was a kid they had a submarine
ride
at Disney World at least it was called
20 000 Leagues Under the Sea
and it was a
I think
a successful movie from the 1950s I
believe
it was what the ride was and that they
have the same ride it's the exact same
[__] ride but now it's called finding
Nimoy
Nemo so not Leonard deanway Nemo and
they they have that uh
they just renamed it so now they put
Nemo underneath it which was actually
pretty cool
you know as far as like Recycling and
they caught it sort of went reverse
Atlanta
who had a perfectly fine football and
baseball stadium and they abandoned both
of them
and built brand new structures that did
not solve any problems whatsoever
Tony Romo is definitely using the
[__] uh
Grecian formula my God
did he is he using
he's got galosh whatever whatever color
that is galoshes
jet black man
um
anyway
Tony Romo should be in Tomorrowland
though they should have him in
Tomorrowland the way he can predict what
the [__] going to happen on a football
field can you imagine what Tony Romo
could have done for the Cowboys if they
didn't give him a new quarterback coach
every [__] year he played for him
um
I don't know I don't even know if that's
true I don't know half the [__] I'm
saying is true let's get out of this
shall we let's let's talk about Helix
everybody helix
Helix sleep is a premium mattress brand
that provides Taylor mattresses based on
your unique sleep preferences the Helix
lineup includes 14 unique mattresses
including a collection of luxury models
a mattress for Big and Tall sleepers and
even a mattress made just for kids
for the kids
uh take the Helix sleep quiz and find
your perfect mattress in under two
minutes and your personalized mattress
is shipped straight to your door free of
charge
um
Helix knows there's no better way to
test out a new mattress than by sleeping
on it
in your own home that's why they offer a
100 night risk-free trial why do I have
the hiccups
sorry
um
interception that'll be the game
um anyway everybody is unique
everybody's special but that doesn't
mean you should comment on a YouTube
video but it does mean that you should
get a mattress that fits you and your
unique
body type right and everyone sleeps
differently that's why Helix Helix has
several different mattress models to
choose from each design for specific
sleep positions and sleep preferences
plus enhanced cooling features to keep
you from overheating at night plus Helix
mattresses are American made that's
right make my mattress in America give a
[__] god job
um and come with a 10 to 15 year
warranty depending on the model that's
[__] great they make them here we
make mattresses we grow weed I don't
know what else we do we don't make the
coke that tastes good which is insane to
me
they got to get the Mexican Coke that
actually has the real sugar in it I
don't understand how that's our formula
we actually came up with this [__] and
they're making it better than we can
right and people want to put a wall up
sorry and remember you
you get to try it out for a hundred
nights risk free
um if you don't learn it and I know you
will but if you don't they will pick it
up for you and give you a full refund oh
boy uh don't want to take my word for it
uh Helix has been awarded the number one
mattress picked by GQ and Wired Magazine
it is even recommended by multiple
leading chiropractors and doctors of
sleep medicine as a go-to solution for
improving your sleep Helix is offering
up to 200 off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for our listeners go to
helixsleep.com
with Helix better sleep starts now
uh
okay this is somebody writing in oh
here's here's a question I have for you
guys
are you married
do you have a spouse
does your spouse abuse you spousal abuse
well if they do listen to another
podcast because that's not what this is
about
um
do you sleep in the same bed
as your uh as your husband a wife
you know
here's my question
if you could be given the option because
last night when we were Disneyland
we were sleeping in this room and it had
like two like queen size beds or maybe
even twins
and my wife and I slept in separate beds
and we both were like
well I just had a that was a great
night's sleep
and Neil was like yeah she goes
should we be like sleeping in separate
beds and I was like I don't know maybe
you know what I mean
would you do it if you know I some
people like a big bed and they can
handle it someone else is in it right
but would you sacrifice
yeah sorry
I'm laying off coffee
um and I haven't taken my old man nap
um would you
take a smaller bed to sleep by yourself
and you're not required to spoon with
anybody or anything
you know but then that becomes a
if you bang who's better you're gonna
bang in and whatnot
I don't know I will tell you this though
uh
sleeping in a bed by yourself and your
wife's in the room in a bed by yourself
it's pretty [__] great it's a very
underrated experience and the first
thing I did was I made fun of it because
I remember back in the day when I would
watch Like The Brady Bunch
in shows like that when I was growing up
they they couldn't show a man and a
woman in the same bed which is [__]
hilarious
because they had six kids obviously
they're [__] right but wait a minute
those they had three step kids and
they're real kids obviously they [__]
somebody else
but they couldn't even suggest it so I
don't know that's my question would you
do that are you doing that
I have no idea all right let's get to
some of the questions here
for the week uh might not be your back
oh last week
last week oh oh Billy threw out his back
um oh my daughter said the funniest [__]
too she went to jump on me like later on
that day and I was like honey no no no
no no no no I was like
it's like I threw out my back
she goes no you didn't dad
you didn't throw up on your back
how would you do that dad you can't like
you know I was just going no throughout
my back
and she was thinking like what does that
mean why would you throw out your back
and it's like
it means I hurt my back it's an
expression all right so this person said
might not be your back
hearing your old bald groans brought me
back to last summer I've had back issues
in the past that were usually cleared up
by a visit to the chiropractor
uh Last Summer the Cairo visit had no
effect and it ended up being a kidney
stone oh Jesus the back pain that left
me groaning
on a heating pad went away
and then came back with a vengeance a
month later with a full-blown Stone
attack
uh more [__] to look forward to all
right well
I don't think it's that it's an old uh
football injury it's literally the first
time I threw out my back it's the same
one
um you know 40 years of this I am
familiar with this pain
but you know I wouldn't rule anything
out at my age
um
is there an app that I can download to
try to figure that out
um I actually
saw one of one of the tailgate Rose Bowl
tailgate Legends Joe bartnick passed a
kidney stone
at the [__] tailgate
um you know when you think you're a man
you then hang out with Joe bartnick and
you realize you're not
[Laughter]
um oh would you look at this I've been
talking films everybody
this week I'm going to watch Cooley High
which I've always heard of I never never
saw it
um but I happen to come across a song it
was that song that the Boyz II Men did
the cover of so I'm going to watch that
this week but this person I love any
suggestions
um for old school movies I have a great
one for you a Dustin Hoffman movie
called straight time I brought it up
about a year ago or so when I watched it
um 100 recommend that movie I got
another great one for you that um will
be a good movie and a funny movie it was
it was about
the the probably I wouldn't say the
generation before me but the kids that
are about four or five years older than
me when they were coming of age in the
70s
and they were building these um housing
projects
out in uh
developments not projects developments
for um you know people who wanted to get
out of the city
and the parents were like double income
it was it was the the nuclear family
the first experiment with that which was
a complete failure
but a lot of can somebody explain James
Brown's hairline for me
okay
um anyway
um
it's called over the edge
Stars a young Matt Dillon uh there's a
couple other character actors in there
that names Escape me
uh that's the one that I always bring up
that has the classic line in there eat
it you stink and pig that's a great one
um to enjoy it's got a great soundtrack
and also to kind of laugh at or whatever
but it's it's it is a good [__] movie
it's a good you know you know what
that's a good movie to take an edible to
and just [__]
far out man and just watch it another
great line any kid that tells on another
kid is a dead kid
all right five greatest underground
movies of all time hi Bill if you
haven't seen these films you are in for
a treat you'll [__] love them I have
I have left trailers
I'm not a big tree I don't like trailers
they show me too much I'll start with
the greatest film of all time
in my humble opinion
apparently it was the second biggest box
office film after Jurassic Park that
year in somewhere like Sweden it's
called Bad Boy bubby
I have no idea what this is about but I
will watch that unless you're [__]
with me and I'll still watch it uh
um
yeah let's see this guy in his [__]
iPhone doing all this dumb [__]
he's he's live Instagram and as we see
uh Nixon live instagramming
um did Nate Burleson get a call at the
last second that he had to go in and do
some [__] playoffs look at him he
looked like he was out
he's dressed like a tennis pro
um all right once with once we're
warriors once were warriors I thought it
was once we were warriors I saw that
that's [__] phenomenal film
phenomenal film and I believe I actually
worked
with one of the actors that was in that
on the Mandalorian if I'm not mistaken
uh meet the phoebies I have no idea what
these are people two hands and boy
I got a [__] up one I can't remember
the name of it but someone will know the
description
and be able to figure out it was about
mental illness
I was looking up underrated movies from
the 1970s and somehow this one came up
and this woman was hearing voices and
[__] and at one point they're driving
out into the country with her husband
and uh
they stop on this to look down basically
at this Cottage it was a really you know
beautiful view so they got out of the
car
and the woman was looking at the
beautiful view and he goes and that's
our Cottage down there and she looked
down at the cottage
and when she looked down there
she saw
the car that they were driving already
there and she saw herself standing down
there looking up staring at her she was
having a staring contest with herself
and then the camera just sucks you in to
her down now you're down in the house
and all of this [__] happens and then
later on in the movie she's looking back
up
address it was [__] Wild
it was really wild I don't know what the
name of the movie is but
sorry
that was a long way to go but I told you
in the beginning that I didn't know what
the [__] it was
um
you know in my heart at heart sometimes
I feel Phil Sims and Boomer Esiason are
actually the same person they just take
the glasses off and they comb the hair
the other way
I don't know convince me otherwise
they're far enough apart where you could
green screen them in the NFL is also and
networks are cheap enough that they'd
only want to pay one person to do two
jobs
um
so that's it the Buffalo Bills are out
of it the Bengals are in and they're
going to play the Kansas City Chiefs in
a rematch I believe right didn't he beat
him the last time he plays [__] Joe
burrow
what is his playoff record
it's got to be impressive
and he smokes cigars you mean you gotta
love that guy
all right National embarrassment
I for some reason feel this is going to
be about my stand-up act dear Bill
Burrough ball Baggins
I listened to your uh podcast for a few
years now I've enjoyed most of it
all right well I got a good average
you're still writing in I got to be
doing something right
um I have enjoyed most of it let's see
here uh especially those wild Alaskan
salmon well you don't know what they're
gonna do man they weren't raised right
when the dad salmon doesn't hang around
the kids salmon they go wild
end up in a grizzly bear's mouth anyway
I'm a rugby fan and I've heard this
argument about what if NFL players
played rugby how good could USA be then
or even NFL rejects I don't know Bill if
you're you know much about American
rugby but you guys suck
yeah we suck at soccer too because we
don't give a [__] about it
those aren't our best athletes
this is so stupid this is like me
trashing you because you guys aren't
good at baseball come on now
all right there we go here we go here we
go here comes the oh right you're not
good at its Australian Rules Football
um anyway you didn't even qualify for
the upcoming 2023 Rugby World Cup hey
here's one for you buddy I didn't even
know that was a thing how about that
what else did we qualify for the the
second annual tea and Crumpet confessed
no one gives a [__] about rugby over
here
failing to make it past Uruguay
uh Chile or the final attempt at
qualifying against Portugal for
perspective the third string of my local
club team just beat Chile 40-3 in
November past this is no perspective
there is no perspective you've come from
a company country that cares about rugby
is invested in it you can make money as
a professional rug you can't make money
playing rugby in the United States of
America there's no money there's no
there's nothing
it isn't even a [__] thing but if it
was a thing our best athletes just out
of curiosity what country are you from
and let's see how we did against each
other in the [__] Olympics
you [__]
tea drinking [__] all right for
perspective okay uh that's how bad USA
are at rugby all right now I'm thinking
this is your second language all right
my my apologies to England
um yeah buddy we don't care about it
anyway but it gets even better in eight
years
in 2031 the U.S will host the Rugby
World Cup Tournament
where in Wichita who [__] paid for
that the best of all uh of the best will
come to your Shores to play and luckily
for you guys the host nation qualifies
automatically
in eight years time you Yanks will
finally have the opportunity to put up
or shut up or be embarrassed on the
international stage
oh no no no no no no no no no no
yeah you're not reading the tea leaves
right
see the reason why we suck at rugby is
because that those are like
as far as level of athlete
that the United States offers like
they're not even in the conversation
okay so you know I mean have fun you
know
put up or shut up I think what they
meant was if an NFL football players
like if Bo Jackson the greatest athlete
I ever saw decided to play rugby
he would [__] run you guys over all
right I'm not saying you wouldn't have
some tough guys but I would put
I would put our best athletes if they
gave a [__] if they were folk what's
what's your Beating sir
is the 30th tier level athlete in the
United States of America it's not a
sport we give a [__] what are we
supposed to dominate all of them
you know what you [__] [__]
around the world you should be [__]
happy that we don't give a [__] about
soccer
you should be [__] happy because if
we did you guys would [__] most of
you would be in trouble
all right
granted the athletes that want it would
be from Africa originally but we would
claim them as ours but I believe you
guys do the same thing
foreign
anyways but we are coming bill
to out muscle you run you over and shove
your face in the dirt where it should be
I have to be honest with you dude I
don't know one rugby term
I hate if you think you [__] [__]
are going to be coming over here you
know what you're gonna have when you
come over here a half-filled stadium
unless you play in like a 5 000 Cedar
nobody gives a [__] about I like rugby I
I appreciate it
um
my money would be on those guys down in
[__] New Zealand
you know
with the greatest pregame of any sport
I've ever [__] seen in my life
anyway okay with the world watching
and the best part is there ain't nothing
you can do about it buddy I can you do
me a favor
can you remind me every day for the next
eight years that this [__] [__] show
is coming so I remember it
um that is [__] hilarious
all right now I want somebody from China
to call in and say how how much you guys
kick our ass in [__] ping pong and
that the national championships are
coming in nine [__] years and you
guys are coming and you're gonna spank
our Yankee [__] fannies with the
paddles I I I don't give a [__] all
right
all right I just wish everything in the
world was like that last email
you know because I usually take the bait
and I gotta be honest with you
um
I hope you run our team over I don't
give I don't what is the name of our
team can we start with that
and since Wayne has rugby had a [__]
World Cup
all right now now I'm curious I gotta
look it up Rugby World Cup
all right
rugby
how do you spell it rugby oh why Rugby
World Cup
um
history
okay Rugby World Cup
the tournament was first held in 1987 oh
Jesus [__] Christ
all right I'll see you in eight years
[__] uh anyway am I the
maybe that was the whole point of that I
will be honest with you when I when I
went over there uh
one of those [__] times I was
watching The Seven Nations League or
whatever
and what I loved about it was if you if
you had the worst record you won they
called it The Wooden Spoon
and I always assumed that meant you're
you're a [__] get in the kitchen like a
woman and go make me a pot of soup you
know some old school sexism [__]
um
I don't know I mean I I do enjoy it um
and I also I I respect your passion sir
but I gotta be honest with you when
you guys trounce us and you run around
America like No One's Gonna know what
you're talking about
foreign
the World Cup in soccer just happened
and it was the greatest final of all the
time and I forgot that it was on okay
and that's soccer
all right rugby I mean Jesus Christ
um
anyway am I the [__]
you'll be great if the greatest rugby
player in the world wore a rug
had a toupee just for the double level
of that you know
am I and then you couldn't make fun of
it but everyone wanted to but he was so
tough no one would
um am I the [__]
dear Strawberry Shortcake
um so here is my story just wanted
to know if you think I was an ass
or if this is funny I guarantee you it's
funny
um all right in the early 90s I worked
mornings at a retail store I would get
off about 1pm
that's a good job
across the street was a dollar theater
showing Second Run movies sometimes I
would go see a show before going home
what are you [__] Lee Harvey Oswald
one day I go and am the only one in the
theater I'm thinking hell yeah then just
as the movie starts five women come in
oh Jesus and sit right in front of me in
an empty theater of course they did they
are talking the whole time all through
the movie dude whatever you said to them
you are not the [__] at first I'm
going to get up and move then I'm like
[__] that I was chewing a big piece of
Hubba Bubba Bubble Gum so I begin
rolling up these tiny balls of gum and
down the line I begin flicking them into
their hair I managed to evenly
distribute two whole pieces
among them without getting caught at the
time I felt this was the perfect Revenge
these years later all these years later
sometimes I wonder go [__] yourself
thanks for all the laughs I mean that
was kind of a chick move to do something
like that
you should have said something
I mean why didn't you just say something
were you afraid they were going to beat
you up and why wouldn't you just be like
you know
hey can you ladies do me a favor and
just quit your [__] yapping
did you have to sit in front of me you
dumb [__] I mean you could have said a
bunch of things what were they going to
do what were they going to do this was
pre-ufc women right
all right Joe Pearl is ridiculously
jacked for a quarterback and none of
this really just
it annoys me how jacked he is I gotta
get in shape man all right Bill great
emails uh please remind the listeners of
the podcast his if you want to write in
the Monday morning podcast I want to
hear some more [__] talk from the three
percent of the world's population that
gives a [__] about rugby
um
Monday Morning podcast at gmail.com
that is the uh
that is the email Monday Morning podcast
all lower all lowercase gmail.com you
can send in your questions and comments
um
all right I will be honest with you I
actually love the sport of rugby
and I like all of those Sports I like
Cricket I like any [__]
Australian Rules Football the reason why
I can make fun of this [__] is because I
watch it
I like the Premier League
the only thing that I will say that I I
I'm not a fan of
is this new slap fight [__] that people
are doing uh I just think nowadays with
all the knowledge that we have about
concussions and CTE and all of that
um
I mean to just sit there and and just
let somebody slap you that hard across
the [__] face like how many times can
you honestly do that I mean
you look at like NFL enforcers
in the amount of headshots those guys
take and they're trying to prevent it
um
here's one for you I don't think there's
a professional fighter
out there that says that they would do
that for a living just for the simple
fact that you have to let yourself
get hit that heart you can't defend you
can't move your head or anything you
have to stand there
that's just uh
I just feel like that's just taken
advantage of people that need money
I don't know why else
you would want to do that
um
but maybe you do I have no idea so
anyway
um
yeah it was a uh it was a great weekend
Ben
um
the uh
I was really sitting like the amount of
[__] over the years especially like
comedians that I saw that had kids this
is my impression of going to Disneyland
and they were doing that whole [__]
thing
of like you know standing in a line and
then turning in directions and [__] like
that
um I only think it did suck though is
they do that big brother [__] where they
wanted to take a picture of you before
you went in there and they go don't
worry we get rid of it at the end of the
day it's like no you don't you don't
you don't so
um
what I would recommend is you go in and
you wear those fake lenses the ones that
color your eyes a different color so
they don't do that retina [__] whatever
the [__] they're doing
I'm already in the system it's too late
for me all right maybe that's why goofy
kept skipping away from me because they
didn't like what they found in their
retina skin
but other than that man it was uh
it was a great time and
you know getting to see
you know my daughter and her best friend
like
they were like freaking out the night
before they had so much energy they were
so freaking excited
and that that's like literally that's
what the experience is is watching them
freaking out like we went to breakfast
they're like oh my God that's Minnie
Mouse like just losing their minds was
just so awesome
uh and also underrated getting to go to
something like that and I don't have to
get on a [__] airplane
uh here's the pro move everybody if
you're from somewhere else fly into John
Wayne do not fly into LAX you want to
kill yourself fly into John Wayne A Long
Beach
smaller airports
um
and then go over there that way and get
yourself the turkey leg
I got a comfortable pair of sneakers I
don't even go in Space Mountain like
that was the one
Space Mountain still is I feel like one
of the iconic ones uh that's left but I
got to be honest with you I don't [__]
with I don't [__] with Six Flags I draw
a hard Line in the Sand I got stuck on a
roller coaster with those guys and I
also saw uh I was out of Six Flags and a
roller coaster rear-ended another one of
this woman [__] broke her cheekbone
and I was like you know what uh I don't
need to be doing this
this [__] Park is open what 24 7 365
just about they're running these rides
when do they have time to maintain them
when do they maintain them when someone
gets stuck on one
maybe they don't
maybe they maybe they're up on it maybe
because you got to think though the odds
are in your favor let's say something
positive about Six Flags they're running
those [__] things all the goddamn
times the level of fatties that get on
that [__] thing and it still goes and
everybody gets back safe all right you
know what
I judged you too fast Six Flags
um
but I am yeah I'm all set on that
I'm all set on Six Flags I don't mind
flying past one
there's a great one up on the five
up by like Magic Mountain whatever you
call I like flying by that one
um but as far as getting on them you
know I don't think so all right so we
got the Cowboys 49ers our next I think
the uh
I'm liking the 49s but everybody I know
thinks the Cowboys
um it makes sense
that the cow well not I don't know I
think a good defense beats a good
offense still I still think that that
happens I'm hanging on to that
that that's going to happen
10 killed 10 wounded
dude what in the [__] is going on in
this world
what is going on in this [__] then
keep [__] showing these things I'm
talking about I'm a big believer and you
don't you shouldn't talk about that
stuff when that [__] happens just
[__] I tell the people that need to
know you don't tell anybody else you
don't glorify the person that did it and
I think it goes away
but I think if you just keeps showing it
right it's like this is like advertising
for psychopaths
um all right
sort of a dark thing to end on but you
know what do you want from me what the
[__] do you want from me all right
that's old freckles my condolence to the
Buffalo condolences to the Buffalo Bills
fans I was [__] rooting for you this
year
uh before
that almost tragic event
um I thought you guys had it God damn it
I still think you're gonna get one
I think he got you know you got
everything in place you just gotta you
gotta have the luck you gotta have all
of that [__] happen for you
um all right so next week next week
is gonna be the Bengals first the Kansas
City Chiefs in Kansas City can Joe
burrow and the Bengals go in there and
upset them again I think that they can
I absolutely think that they can
uh
uh all right that's it now they're
showing pictures of this guy this guy's
still at large fantastic
[__] lunatic all right go [__]
yourselves
I'll see you I'll check in on you on
Thursday